we've had this phrase obviously used in
the last year in particular which is
following the science
yes right when it comes to other things
have we been following the science on
drugs
no we've been actively denying the
science
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
francis foster i'm constantine kitten
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations
with fascinating people we have a
brilliant guest for you today he's a
neuropsychopharmacologist and he was
dismissed from his role advising the
government on drug policy
uh back under the blair government i
believe dr david nutt welcome to
trigonometry
good to be here thank you did we get
your introduction right
you did it was the brown government it
was the brown government even worse
so it's good to have you on listen we we
started the show three years ago and you
were literally one of the names at the
very top of our list we we didn't manage
to make it happen
until now so i you can tell i'm very
excited to have you on the show
tell everybody before we get into it a
little bit about who are you
how are you where you are what has been
the journey through life that leads you
to be sitting here talking to us
so i am a psych doctor
trained as large as a psychiatrist uh
but as you said i am a
neuropsychopharmacologist and that is
someone that studies the effects of
pharmacology on the brain
why do i do that because the brain is a
chemical organ
your brain communicates all the neurons
in your brain communicate with each
other by chemicals
80 different chemicals in the brain and
in order to understand the brain you
have to understand the chemicals and to
understand the chemicals you have to use
drugs to manipulate them
so as part of my work and my research i
i think i've achieved something that's
rather special i think i have
administered more different kinds of
drugs
to human beings in any one alive pretty
much every class of drug that has ever
been given to someone to change the
brain i've given
and so i know quite a lot about drugs in
the brain and that's why the government
20 years ago asked me to join them to
advise them on drug policy because i was
an expert on drugs
but after 10 years of doing research on
the harms of drugs i came to the
conclusion
which wasn't surprising i suppose that
current drug policy and the current drug
laws weren't based on evidence and then
i started saying that
publicly and they didn't like that so
they sacked me
that is so funny but look what a lot of
people don't know
the the the actual scientific evidence
um i
suppose there will be things lots of us
don't know can you talk to us about
which drugs are actually harmful
including the legal and the legal ones
and which drugs are less harmful than
others so we can kind of get a picture
of
if everything was allowed to be taken
which drugs would be doing the most
damage and which would be
the safest sure well we did a very very
systematic analysis there are 16 ways in
which drugs can harm you
wow there are nine harms to the user and
they range from
killing you as soon as you take it like
fentanyl or you know making you go
slightly crazy perhaps like
uh like a psychedelic uh and then there
are
seven harms of society so if you if all
drugs were legal
and and they were equally used the most
dangerous drugs
which would harm the most number of
people would be drugs like heroin
fentanyl crack cocaine crystal meth
but then quite soon after you'd come to
alcohol alcohol is about the fifth or
sixth most harmful drug to the user
and the thing i got really angry with
about with the government was that the
drugs which are relatively
less harmful drugs like ecstasy like lsd
like magic mushrooms
they're the ones that attract the
highest penalties even though they're
much less harmful than drugs like even
alcohol
you you say that i'm i'm going to ask
you this question
and i've wanted to ask it to you for a
very long time so
when i started in comedy i was a fan of
bill hicks the comedian and
when he used to have this routine about
have you ever noticed it's the drugs
that do the least for you that are legal
the ones that get you to question
to push back to think for yourselves are
made illegal
do you agree with that totally genius he
was a genius absolutely completely on
track
the drugs that make you question this
the establishment
question of governments drugs like
psychedelics
they were banned lsd was banned because
people were questioning the war in
vietnam
and because at that time as is still the
case today the only
response of western governments to drugs
is to ban them they got banned
it didn't affect people using them but
it absolutely hammered people like me
who want to research them and want to
use them as therapies
and why is it that we just can't have a
very simple rational discussion about
this
without it invoking p you know people
getting very angry
upset you know blanket bands which have
been proven time and time again not to
work
yeah that's a really interesting
question why can't we have a rational
discussion
it's because i think now it's been so
long
that we've been lying about the harms of
drugs that
the people even people who kind of know
intellectually
that they're like these the the relative
harms are lie you know
the drugs that are banned because of
lies they even the people that know the
truth
kind of feel uncomfortable about telling
the truth and i think obviously a lot of
people do believe that lies and they do
believe
that drugs like lsd are more harmful
than alcohol which is of course
completely wrong
and we've had this phrase obviously used
in the last year in particular which is
following the science
yes right when it comes to other things
have we been following the science on
drugs
no we've been actively denying the
science and we've been denying the
science
do you know what it was you know where
it all started it started in
uh 1914 with the opium act the opium act
was brought in
at kind of at the behest of
pharmaceutical companies
who didn't want people using plant
products they didn't like people smoking
opium they wanted people to use the
extr the pure extract of opium which is
called morphine which they had patented
and in fact they patented other extracts
like codeine and heroin
so there was an antipathy to using plant
products then
it was sort of gaining control of the
markets by the by
big farmer particularly german pharma
companies
but in order to get opium banned
he couldn't just ban it because it was
competing with farming what they had to
do was create
the fear of opium and that was very easy
you just
created a fear of chinese you know and
in london was you know the east end of
london where we are now you know this
was
you know basically chinese people living
here were
smoking opium and they would create you
know hysteria was created about them
being evil people and they were
corrupting them
you know particularly young women
getting them smoking opium
and so that the fear you know that this
was generated around chinese people
smoking opi both in here and in the
states
to get opium banned that was the
beginning of it and then then it rolled
on then
the biggest sea change came with the uh
the prohibition of america
of alcohol in america and that was
driven by right very puritanical
individuals you know lobby groups and
they were concerned
quite understandably concerned about the
damage that alcohol was doing to
families
so rather than have a rational policy to
alcohol which would be through taxation
and limiting access
they banned it and it wasn't just
america sweden norway finland also
banned alcohol
we nearly did in this country people
don't realize in
i think it was in the 1923 election
winston churchill stood in dundee
against the temperance candidate and the
temperance candidate beat
churchill by i think about 15 000 votes
so there's a huge international pressure
to ban alcohol anyway the american
succumbed alcohol got banned what
happened
well hell let loose organized crime rose
because people like alcohol and people
weren't prepared to give it up
just to protect but possibly protect you
know the families that were being
damaged
hey well what's that got to do with
modern drugs well what happened was in
1932 i think or 33
the prohibition act got repealed but at
that point
because prohibition was so corrupting of
the police every policeman in america
was on the take from speakeasies because
every street corner
had a speakeasy you're underground you
get your boots so the police were all
corrupt so
the american government created a
special army which we now call the drug
enforcement agency
to fight the mafia and just try to stop
people using alcohol
and that ended up being about 35 000
people
uh run by a man called harry anslinger
and suddenly one day
he knew that alcohol was going to be
legal so he couldn't be fighting alcohol
anymore
he'd lose his job had all his men would
lose his job so what did he do
he created a new monster which was
cannabis
and he changed the name from cannabis to
marijuana
because it's mexican and then he started
the classic process that all governments
do when
they want to ban a drug they associate
it with some other group
in this case the mexicans and then the
same stories the stories we had about
the chinese corrupting
white people became the mexicans were
correctly white people the mexicans were
coming into america
and selling cannabis and young men were
going crazy and they were killing their
mothers etc
so he created a hysteria about cannabis
but worse than that he persuaded the
rest of the world to be hysterical about
cannabis
and in 1934 the league of nations which
america wasn't even part of
banned cannabis effectively worldwide
and that really started the whole chain
you know chain reaction of just
keep banning any drug you don't like
until we got to the 1968 war on drugs
with nixon where
you know he just went right over the top
in order to get elected
and and we're talking about it now but
it does seem that we're
starting to have a more balanced
approach
starting for example new york have i
think they've legalized cannabis
have they not do you think that's part
of a wider trend david that we're seeing
now
yeah well the debates happened i think
to be honest my sacking was
made a contribution in this country to
the debate because people said well why
has it been sacked and they said because
he's saying that
alcohol is more harmful than lsd and the
cannabis should be
illegal because it's less harmful than
alcohol and people start saying really
oh but he's a scientist oh maybe maybe
he's right
you know you
secretary allen johnson sacking me
saying i think i was wrong on
the harms of cannabis i mean who are you
going to believe you know you're going
to believe at least me because i
have done some research you know i i do
have a sort of integrity and i do have
some knowledge
david why do people take drugs well
everyone takes drugs
so that that's including the people who
make the laws against them
right let's be clear about this almost
so the first thing to say is that
taking drugs is one of the core features
of humanity if you what defines us as
different from other primates
well we have language we have art
and we take drugs those are the three
things that distribution we seek out
drugs why do we do that because we have
a hell of a big brain
and we understand that there's a lot of
capacity in the brain which is
underutilized
so humans have always sought out drugs
and that generally
it's for pleasure or to reduce pain so
on 1998
of the world's population take drugs i
mean mostly they take drugs like tea or
coffee
coffee you know you're having one now
yeah i have one now that's right
naughty boy 80 of adults drink uh drink
alcohol
about what used to be 60 70 percent of
people smoke tobacco now it's a lot less
people take drugs to relax them
to take away some of the stress of life
and in some cases to actually expand
their understanding of life
and that's where drugs like psychedelics
and maybe mdma come in
and we've always taken
these drugs and it just it just seems
bizarre that we live in a society which
is abandoned because
yes magic mushrooms were banned went i
think it was 2005. correct
and what was the government's what was
their justification for banning
it do you wanna know the story there
yeah so this is it so
david cameron had come in to become the
leader of the tory party
and he said before he became leader that
one of his
ambitions was to reduce the
classification of mdma which is a class
agency schedule one drug
in fact mdma at that time in 2000 2004
people were getting longer prison
sentences
for mdma than for heroin or crack wow
why is that because judges hate people
having fun
seriously they don't admit that of
course but that just happens
that's the only that's the only rational
explanation okay so cameron said i'm
going to reduce
mdma from class a to class b i think
largely because he was associated with a
lot of people that were taking it
you know his wife was quite quite a
raver she went to raise you know it was
a popular drug and it was people it was
a drug which you know was changing
particularly people's attitude to the
police the police would go to a rave and
for the first time in their life they'd
be hugged
when they went to a pub they got beaten
up anyway so there's a strong move
to it for that um mdma was going to be a
more open openly available cameron
became
at the head of the tory party the next
day i mean you know i monitored this
obviously because i was a government
advisor at the time i monitored it
one day you know i'm going to review the
drug laws the next day
you know i thought about it i've decided
mdma a really dangerous drug the drug
laws you know we're going to stick with
the current classification
he swapped overnight he switched then
what did he do
he people started selling in camden come
to market
they start a couple of shops started
head shops started selling dried
mushrooms
the technology for freeze drying magic
mushroom came along
the daily mail did not like that the
daily mail has always had hysteria
against
drugs and they goaded cameron
to do something about these two shops
selling magic mushrooms so cameron then
go did blair
and said look you know you're soft on
drugs we've got a drug here because the
active ingredient of magic mushrooms is
psylocybene which is illegal if it was
pure but the mushrooms were legal in
this country and blair because he was
like many left wingish
governments more liberal governments are
terrified of being
seen as soft on drugs i mean the classic
example of course is clinton in america
clinton brought in the most
restrictive regulations he's the guy
that brought in the third strike and
you're in prison forever
yeah because he was told he had to be
harder than the republicans otherwise he
wouldn't get elected same here blair's
decided he'd have to be harder on drugs
than cameron
and instead of coming to the expert
group by
the acmd which i was a part of instead
of asking us for advice which he should
have done by law
he set up his own committee we don't
know what i mean it's alleged because of
course it was none of it's documented
but this was a classic blair
the kitchen cabinet you know i think
they call it the sofa cabinet
he got in he got in the police he got in
he got in the army and they sat around
and they decided what are they going to
do about magic mushrooms i mean it's
kind of completely bizarre
and we as the experts and the
government's formal advisors heard that
they were having these meetings and we
said to them you cannot
change the law of magic mushrooms
without consulting the acmd because that
is what the law says the ministry of
drug
act says you cannot change the law
without consulting
the experts and they went quiet for a
couple of weeks
and and then we got a note saying that
we're going to have a vote in in
in in the commons next week on
rescheduling
and reclassifying magic and we and they
said what do you think and we said
that's
an insult you kind of you've reached the
law and you can't put us on that spot we
can't give us three days effectively to
make a
a proper harm assessment because it
takes a few months to do that and so
they went ahead without us and then they
voted
they voted to to ban magic restaurants
and make magic restaurants a class a
drug
and that that was actually the beginning
of the end for me
because you're sitting here saying magic
mushrooms one you know a million people
are using him each
year in britain and no harm and then
suddenly they're alongside crack cocaine
what kind of law making is that and that
was you know at that point we'd be
i began to rubble and start saying you
know come on guys you know this
you can't have decisions just made by by
essentially by the prime minister and a
couple of coronies and
we're talking about magic mushrooms
you've been heavily involved in the
field of psychedelics
do you think that this is the next phase
for medicine you know as a way to treat
things like anxiety depression etc etc
absolutely i mean it's like in the 1950s
and 60s particularly lsd was being
heralded as a revolution it was the
really the first
medicine we had for the mind and it was
being
widely used so there are a thousand
research papers published in the 1950s
and 60s on lsd
showing powerful effective treatments
for everything from anxiety
depression addiction and then he got
banned he got banned because of the
vietnam war because you know people
thought
the anti-war protest will go away if
it's behind the list
[Laughter]
i mean it is a classic adage isn't it
you know if you're a hammer everything's
a nail you know if you're a
drug policy person everything's a ban
anyway so
that ban had destroyed research it's the
worst censorship of research
in the history of world of all research
because i think 227 countries in the
world signed up to that ban
in no country in the world his lsd
subsequently been studied as a treatment
except a tiny study in switzerland where
it was invented
and when you look back at the evidence
and you know the fact that lsd treatment
for alcoholism is the most powerful
treatment
it's twice as powerful as the best
modern treatment
and yet you can't use it because it's
illegal and that's why i started
and my team you know 10 15 years ago and
i started fighting back because it
it makes no sense it's not as if the ban
has stopped use
all it's done is stopped researching
clinical clinical attempts
and so i'm going to wear a tin foil hat
and i'm going to ask you a tim for hat
question and
feel free to push back do you think part
of the reason
that we have been so wary
with this particular aspect with things
like psychedelics and treating mental
health
is because of big pharma who've got
their own particular treatments
and don't want them to be encroached
upon yeah there's several answers to
that question
it's more it's not simple that they i
think
it's possible i don't have any evidence
but it's possible in the 90s
towards the end of the 1950s other
treatments for psychiatry were coming
along
non-psychedelic treatments and i think
one of the justifications
that governments used to get rid of lsd
was well we've got the alternatives
yeah we've got antidepressants uh so i
think
i think i don't think pharma is trying
to get rid of lsd but but i think
maybe they were i don't know we don't we
haven't got any data on that but
certainly
governments could say well we don't need
it because we got alternatives
and that's essentially when you put a
driving drug in schedule one which they
did in this country in the u.n
conventions
that says that you don't need it because
it's very dangerous and because there
are alternatives
now more recently i don't i actually
think that in a strange way i think the
pharmaceutical industry is pleased with
what we're doing
because they have given up on developing
brain treatments
as one of the vice presidents of gsk
said 10 years ago he said
any drug company that works in on the
brain needs a head red
because it's too difficult and that's so
that most of them have now well in fact
almost no drug companies work
on new treatments of the brain they
almost all work in cancer and heart
disease and
really is that really true yeah that's
incredible i mean
we bang on about mental health more than
ever and rightly so
you know you could argue certainly for
some people the treatment is needed but
they're not
they're not looking to to deal with that
market they're not looking to find
solutions
i think it's too difficult really and so
i think they're quite grateful that
we're finding the solutions
but the problem is the solutions are
still illegal and until we change the
law
we can't roll it out to the millions of
people who need it and so you were
saying about you know
and push back if i'm wrong that this is
the the psychedelics are more effective
than the synthetics and the
antidepressants can you
explain to us why and yes because they
work in a very different way
and this is really the nub of my
research i mean just just to be just
explaining a little bit more when
i started researching psychedelics
because it was the last class of drug i
hadn't studied i started everything else
stimulants opiates you know you name it
i've given it to humans
but we haven't done psychedelics why
because it was just difficult and they
were illegal
and then i thought well you know i'm 60
now if we don't start soon i won't ever
get it done so we started
and then we found these weird things you
know we've found that you know although
they open up your mind
they actually switch off your brain so
the brain goes
brain activity goes down as your mind
expands and and in fact
well it's remarkable about that because
that's exactly what arduos actually
predicted
in 1953 when he took masculine he wrote
about it in the doors of perception
and he said my mind has been expanded by
this drug
what does that mean oh it means that
something's constraining my mind
what's constraining my mind must be my
brain
and he came up with this wonderful
phrase the brain is an instrument for
focusing the mind
and we showed exactly that because when
we switch the brain off the mind expands
so that was the first thing that you
know we completely turned everything on
our head
no one expected that these drugs would
switch off the brain except huxley
because he was dead
but then we showed that it switches off
the parts of the brain which drive
conditions like anxiety and depression
so then we thought well maybe they'll
maybe it'll work in these conditions and
that and then i started reading what
people knew about them in the 50s and
60s and i realized well it was obvious
you know but we had the brain science
now we could actually go
to ethics committees and say we can
switch off the part of the brain that
caused depression
can we do a study and they said well it
took us two years to get permission but
in the end we've got permission and it
was it was
cytosimin is the most powerful treatment
a single dose of psilocybin
can lift depression in the vast majority
of people
with severe depression people who've
been untreatable for 20 years can get
better
a day after a trip really and by
by better what do you mean david well
some are cured some of the people we
treated in the night we started doing
the study in 19 sorry 2013.
and some about 20 of the people in that
first trial are still
are still well now most have not most of
relapse because depression is
from people who've had depression for
decades often many people start having
depression in childhood because they get
abused
their brain becomes set in a depressed
mode and and we can suppress that
but it kind of creeps back and you so
but
but it is still the most powerful
treatment single treatment of depression
that's ever been shown
david let me ask you francis normally is
the one wearing the tinfoil hat but i'll
put one on for this purpose as well he
mentioned bill hicks and this idea that
the drugs we are allowed to take are a
certain type of drug and if you look at
them you know
tea coffee tobacco alcohol whatever
these tend to be drugs that facilitate
us being in the world as it is yes being
obedient workers going into the factory
going into the office
sitting there taking another shot of
coffee to to be able to stay at the
computer
whereas as you say drugs that can be
blamed for
opening people's minds getting them to
question authority
reject whatever they're being told that
they're supposed to support
invasions of other countries whatever
they are the ones that tend to be
illegal is that a connection you see as
relevant or is that just
totally totally yeah politicians are
absolutely terrified of mine opening
drugs because it changes the way people
vote
that you know that was kind of the basis
of the war on drugs
nixon's war on drugs they you know they
were really determined to try to portray
peop the anti-war people as crazy drug
users they wanted to frame
rebellion and protest with drug use and
they succeeded
and we and we bought into that you know
basically
our misuse of drugs act in 20 uh sorry
in them
1971 was essentially written by the
americans i mean basically
they told us you get you write this you
know basically your drugs out has got to
mirror ours otherwise
whatever i don't know we're not going to
put nuclear submarines in somewhere
anyway
you know we we had up to that point kind
of resisted
doing exactly what they told us but by
then in 1971 we gave up
so let's uh there's two other things i
want to
focus on in the car because we have
we're having a very positive
conversation
about drugs which some people may feel
is in
gives un not enough attention to the
negatives
um so let's talk about addiction yes
and the fears that people have
about legalizing or decriminalizing
drugs
the impact of that because as you said
yourself there's 16 ways that drugs can
harm
people including society in general so
if we were to decriminalize or legalize
drugs or most drugs would that not have
a huge negative
impact in terms of you know people just
getting addicted
being stuck in negative cycles whatever
well that's exactly what the politicians
say yeah that is the
fear that politicians can spout all the
time
if we change the law it will expand use
and expand harms and there are multiple
arguments against that well better than
arguments there's loads of evidence
against that
so the first thing is that the law
doesn't work so we have
illegal cannabis in this country you
know recreational cannabis is illegal
yet we have a greater proportion of
young people using cannabis than they
have in countries where it's legal
why is that well and that's kind of been
well known since the 1950s really
illegal markets creates
demand and they create demand by getting
people to use drugs and then selling
drugs
so once you criminalize people for drug
use
they don't have much options if you get
as we've got a million young people a
lot of them
you know black and you know a minority
ethnic
with criminal records for cannabis
possession they can't get jobs in the
police or in teaching or the civil
service he's even quite difficult to get
into the army with a criminal record for
cannabis
so we've got a million people what what
do you do then if you can't work in
conventional work you deal drugs and
perhaps the worst example of that was is
was was heroin so in
in 1971 this is one of the exam one of
the really
terrible examples of what america forced
us to do we were prescribing heroin to
heroin addicts until 1971
because we knew that if we didn't they
would
go to the black market and get it but
the americans hated us for that and they
effectively said you've got to stop
doing that
so we stopped doing that now you take a
heroin addict who's getting a
prescription from the doctor on a
you know regular basis and you say sorry
you can't have your hearing anymore
what did they do they don't say oh
that's all right i'll go and
i'll go and run a marathon or something
they say i got four hours
i got four hours to get my next hit and
who
who do you go to to get to get heroin in
four hours will you go to the black
market you go to the criminal and where
do you get the money for
it that's the other part of it well
that's right so then you yeah you can
get your drug you can get someone will
give you the heroin and then they say
yeah they want a hundred quid
you know back in those days back in 97
was a lot of money and then how do you
get the money where you either steal
from your parents or your you know your
partners or you prostitute yourself
or then you become a drug dealer and
that's what happened
the majority of heroin users from 70 to
80 to 90 became heroin dealers in order
to pay for their habits
so we went from a thousand addicts to
three hundred thousand addicts
in twenty years wow and we documented
that there was an amazing case
one herron addict went to crawley down
in
in in sussex i've been to quarter you
shouldn't go to crawl
and they've traced it they showed that i
think this person had bigger problems
that one person created i think about 25
other heroin addicts
in crawley they what they it was like an
infection they wanted to how he gra
and they gradually grew and grew and all
and each one has to then get other
addicts so it's like a ponzi scheme
now we knew this nobel winning
prize-winning
economists have said this is what
happens we've known this forever but
but people don't governments don't want
to believe it because
uh it confronts their moral
sensitivities about being rational about
drugs
and then just to finally answer your
question completely there's brilliant
evidence
it's called portugal it's a portugal
decriminalized personal possession of
all drugs
about 17 years ago now why because it
was
pursuing the policies that we polish but
we
we follow and the other countries follow
was bankrupting them
so they decriminal but what's happened
to their drug use and now
we've now got data on 15 years of
decriminalization in portugal
heroin deaths have fallen to a third of
what they were before
over the same time in britain heroin
deaths have risen
to two-thirds of what they before every
year in britain we get
a record number of heroin deaths because
we don't
treat them in a portugal someone gets
arrested for possessing a heroin they
don't get put in prison
they get treated and that means they
stop
creating other addicts and they can be
they stop dying because they get
treatment
so the portuguese experiment has
absolutely shown us
how you can have a rational policy that
works and saves huge amounts of money
because they empty their prisons
in britain we have or doubled our prison
population
in the last 30 years and all of that
is drug related crime and the the dutch
and the portuguese with more sensible
drug laws have actually managed to
reduce their prison population
this is what i wish people would
understand we talk about all sorts of
issues on the show whether that's
you know racial inequality the policing
racism immigration in america all of
these things that are driving the
political landscape in
very powerful ways actually i mean how
many of the people coming through the
southern border in in
from latin america are escaping drug
cartel operated countries how many
people are in prison because
they're there because of of you know
things that
wouldn't shouldn't be illegal in my
opinion you know absolutely i mean
yeah i mean when you create a narco
state which is what mexico is and to
some extent what
you know some even some of the west
african countries now guinea bissau
you've you actually completely
destabilized the the state you disable
the economy you make it
you essentially create you know the
state is run by drug dealers and and
they're generally not very good in
people and they're generally not that
concerned about the welfare of the
population overall
so you know we've created that monster
particularly in south america and that's
in america
which is actually fueling this enormous
you know desire to get out of there and
get somewhere that's actually less
oppressive and horrible
hey francis do you think it's cool that
the same company that controls 50
of online retail also passively
eavesdrops on every conversation you
have in your home
what what about the idea that a single
company controls
ninety percent of internet searches and
gets to track
everything you do on your smartphone i'm
so
screwed you are trigonometry is now
going to be a solo project
big tech is more powerful than most
countries are and they profit by
exploiting your personal data
it is time to put a layer of protection
between your online activity
and these tech juggernauts that is why i
use expressvpn
unfortunately so sadly every site you
visit every video you watch
every message you send gets tracked and
data mined but
when you run expressvpn on your device
the software hides your ip address
something big tech can use to personally
identify you so
expressvpn makes your activity harder to
trace and sell to advertising
absolutely and the best part is how easy
it is to use
download the app on your phone or
computer tap just one button
and you're protected francis please stop
crying my new shoes are getting wet
if you don't want to end up like me and
want to protect yourself from big tech
go to slash expressvpn.com
and get three extra months for free
that's e x p r e
s s v p and dot com
slash trigger to learn more
david to you what is a good
drug policy if you are in charge of the
drug policy now
what laws and changes would you
implement
so if i was running everything yeah i
would um
i would actually have a i would
decriminalize
personal possession of all drugs so that
people go into treatment rather than
prison because i mean putting people in
prison for drugs is just stupid because
they actually end up taking more drugs
in prison
when you say treatment just to interject
briefly
tell people a little bit about what you
mean by that
well if you are addicted to a drug if
you're if you're caught in possession of
a drug and you're
because you're addicted to it then i
would say you're mentally ill
because that's what an addiction is so
you should be
treated as uh someone who is ill rather
than someone who is bad
but putting drug addicted people into
prison
is both extremely wasteful of money
because it cost a lot of money to put
people in prison
and it just perpetuates the cycle
because they don't get treated in prison
i mean drug use in prison is greater
than outside of prison
for various reasons not least of which
prison's a horrible place and drugs
can't help people deal with the misery
and also
you know a significant proportion of um
prison officers and no drug dealers
because there's a lucrative trade so
criminalizing people for drug use is
always counterproductive
right so you arrest people uh if you
find people with drugs in their
possession you decriminalize that they
get treatment and that's a combination
of like psychological and medical and
whatever
whatever they need right okay and then
now if they're not addicted
then and this is the weakness of the
decriminalization approach
is what you do well in portugal what
they do is they have civil sanctions
they basically say okay well you've got
to clean the streets for a couple of
weeks
so you don't get a criminal record and
that's critical you mustn't give people
criminal records
but they they pay some kind of penalties
they call it dissuasion
now my own personal view is i would go
further than that
and my view is if for drugs which are
less
harmful to the user than alcohol
then they should be available because i
think for two reasons
first is a moral reason why would you
want people to take a more harmful drug
if they could take a less harmful drug
well the only reason for that is because
the drinks industry want you to
and then the second reason is a
pragmatic reason if people use less
harmful drugs there's less harm
and this myth that people politicians oh
well they'll
they'll be taking alcohol and they'll be
getting stoned on top and they'll be i
mean that's just rubbish
you know about a third of people in
britain if if cannabis was legal would
reduce their drinking they'd switch to
cancer i wouldn't have another drop of
alcohol ever again
personally yeah so so there will be
almost certainly overall health benefits
for making a more
uh but i'd have this i'd have these
drugs available in what we in what we
call
you know licensed premises like
pharmacies you know where we get their
drugs
and just reflect on the fact that until
1974
we used to just sell alcohol in licensed
premises which were called bars or off
licenses
and then one of the worst things that
any government did and this was john
major's government
was to allow supermarkets to sell booze
and the massive increase in alcohol harm
which we've seen
has been driven by um i think about 90
it was about 94
that he opened up uh essentially the
licensing laws
and and we alcohol consumption
effectively doubled
as a result of allowing people to buy in
supermarkets or the increase in alcohol
consumption since
the mid-90s has been in supermarkets and
that
doubling of alcohol consumption has led
to a tripling of alcohol harms
because there's a kind of this is the
relationship between alcohol consumption
and harm is not linear it's actually
curvilinear
and so you decriminalize possession
and what do you do for people who are
dealing drugs like crystal meth etc etc
would you legalize something like that
or would you still make it illegal so i
think drugs
they're more harmful than alcohol so i
would keep that i would keep
so the dealers would still be criminal
in the same way as people who are
bringing in
illegal alcohol you know they're
criminals as well you know if you've got
to if you've got a regulated market
then you have to protect it so if if
people are deliberately flatting the law
by by bringing in drugs which
uh are more harmful than the ones people
could buy then yes i think you have to
criminalize them
but the hope would be that their market
would dwindle because if you've got
look we've seen this we've can any of
you remember methadrone mcat meow meow
yeah i remember yeah remember that right
so this is an amazing example of of how
rational drug use or drug users are so
in 2007
began to come into britain so this is a
it was a legal category
okay and it was actually pretty safe you
could take a gram of methadrone
and you wouldn't die whereas if you took
grammar cocaine there's a good chance
you'll die
so and if you took a gram of mdma that
really is good so
so people started to switch particularly
from
cocaine and amphetamines to methadrome
which is a kind of weak
cocaine really and uh and cocaine deaths
fell
year on year cocaine deaths so the
cocaine deaths halved
and amphetamine deaths reduced by about
40
when people had access to something that
was not killing them but
not equally acceptable but preferable
because it was legal
but what happened the government got
hysterical sorry that the sun got
absolutely hysterical the sun determined
it was going to ban methadrome
and it and it set out to you know to
create scare stories about methadrone
and they and it was the government it
was a 2010 election
brown was getting anxious about being
seen as weak on drugs
so they they decided to ban method just
before the election
and what happened cocaine deaths then
rose and rose and rose we now have the
highest number of cocaine deaths we've
ever had
method drones deaths would wouldn't
there were never really any methadone
drifts they stayed virtually
zero so people are rational people if
you give
them a safer legal alternative
they will use it and that will save
lives so that's the model on which i'm
making the argument that we should have
a regulated market
for some drugs and where do you stand on
cocaine david
yeah cocaine's a tricky one actually and
i'm i'm interested in whether
we could have a regulated market now the
the organization could transform
he's actually just written a paper
because that they're trying to see if
you can get a regulated cocaine market
in mexico
because that could dramatically
undermine
the power of the cartels so i think if
mexico go down that route that'll be
very you know we could monitor that and
see how it goes
i think cocaine is on the edge it's more
harmful than alcohol
but it's is it so much more harmful that
you might
there might be benefits in having a
regulated market
in the sense you get rid of organized
crime so you know that i think that's
the most difficult one it presents
david let's talk about addiction a
little bit yeah because i think this is
a very important part because i think uh
you talk about the political reluctance
to to follow the science good to use the
the the term
uh and it's clear from what you're
saying that you know
that political those political decisions
are killing people but
they are based i think the politicians
make their decisions based on their
perception of the public
yes perception of drugs and the public's
perception of drugs may be at a sort of
individual level well i don't want my
child
i don't want this i don't want that and
we do see
people and you know even with with drugs
that are not in and of themselves
massively harmful like heroin but people
people have problems with alcohol people
problems cannabis people have problems
with all sorts all sorts of drugs right
why do people get addicted to drugs
so the three main drivers to get
addicted to drugs the first is the drug
some drugs are more addictive than
others heroin cocaine
are very addictive alcohol is pretty
addictive tobacco is pretty addictive
and some drugs are not addictive mdma
lsd
other psychedelics they're not they're
anti-addictive they're not addictive so
that's the first thing the drug varies
the second thing is the nature of the
drug varies and the way you take it so
if you're
in shooting up crack cocaine
or or smoking crack cocaine you know you
it gets in the brain so fast that it
is more addictive than for instance if
you snort cocaine and that's one of the
reasons actually
we encourage people to smoke heroin
rather than inject heroin because again
it's not just safer in terms of
infection but it's also a bit less
addictive
so the speed at which the drug gets in
it has quite a huge impact on on
addictiveness and we can easily
and we can use that to actually develop
treatments but that's another story
and then the the really the third thing
is why are people using the drug
so if you're using it if you're using
the drug to dampen pain
yeah you know then you're less likely to
get addicted if you're using the drug to
get high
because getting high eventually for most
drugs they're getting heart the effect
the high gets less and less so people
keep chasing the higher
if you're using say alcohol though to do
with pain or misery in your life then
you can get
because you get tolerance to alcohol
then you've got to keep more and more so
so it's
you need to look carefully as to why
people are using drugs and if it's for
self-medication
that's generally not a good thing you
know you're vulnerable there
and then the final point and this is
particularly relevant to cannabis why do
people get to treated to cannabis they
didn't used to get
into cannabis very much when i was an
undergraduate people using cannabis
there's much more addiction to cannabis
now because
our policy has changed the cannabis
market back in the 70s and 80s
cannabis was a resin or hash it was a
mixture of bit of thc you know maybe
five milligrams of thc in a spliff you
know maybe but also a thing called
a substance called cannabidiol which is
a kind of antidote and
a balanced mixture of traditional
cannabis isn't very addictive
but because we are hysterical about
stopping the importation
of you know moroccan or lebanese plants
you know we've got homegrown cannabis
and
people then now are going hydroponically
under
permanent light and that grows strong
thc
without cannabidiol so 95 of the stuff
you buy in britain called cannabis
is skunk and it's up to 15 to 20 thc
which is more addictive because it's
stronger than the old stuff but also
hasn't got the protective element
so our policies have driven absolutely
driven
the rise in harms from cannabis but then
it gets worse
we're the one we're the only country in
the world it just has really got a big
problem with spice synthetic
cannabinoids
and we've caused that we have created
the spice monster
because we have tried to stop prisoners
using cannabis we started testing
prisoners
for cannabis which hangs around in the
body for uh
for weeks you know when we started
testing back in the early 90s it was an
experiment just to see what
what drugs prisoners were using i'm
turning out prisoners were using
a lot of cannabis they they carried on
testing
and they basically if you tested
positive for cannabis you lost your
probation so you could stay in prison
for two more years
now prisoners are not stupid so they
switch the first thing they switched to
which you well documented the government
they switched to heroin
because heroin disappears in the day so
then we had a rise in heroin using
prisons because people
i mean isn't that the most ridiculou a
policy which drives people from
cannabis to heroin you know you think oh
hang on perhaps we should stop doing
this procedure's not testing no no we
just carry on rolling out testing
because we want to stop people using
heroin
and then they switch to ghb and
gabapentins and then someone realized
that you could actually have these
synthetic cannabinoids which aren't
detectable and so now we have in prisons
we've had 70 deaths last year from
synthetic cannabinoids
these extremely toxic compounds that
prisoners are using to avoid
detection for using cannabis every
prison in britain now has to have a
special
platoon of big male paramedics to deal
with the people who go crazy and who
have heart attacks and have fits
from synthetic cannabinoids no other
country in the world has this problem
but because we're so obsessed with
punishing people
even when they're in prison by testing
them testing them we've created this
monster
and can we put it back in the bottle you
know one we've seen it on the streets
you know the streets of manchester a
couple of years ago
it's cheaper to get stoned on synthetic
cannabinoids
than it is on alcohol so people switch
and they're you know they're so much
more toxic
it just seems that we've seen that that
we're just making the same mistake
again and again totally and again are we
ever going to actually wake up and deal
with this in a calm and rational manner
well we did have a sense of when the
really sad thing
there was an opportunity in the
coalition because
the lib dems were very sympathetic to
a sensible policy in fact the lib dems
now have a policy of legal cannabis
it's just that they don't have any you
know they can't even touch power anymore
no no but when in the coalition that
there was a lib dem
minister for drugs norman baker
and he was very sensible very rational
in fact he's he's on one of my upcoming
podcasts
and he went around the world and he got
evidence of
better policies around the world he was
not allowed to
he's a drug minister he couldn't publish
his own paper
because at the time the home secretary
someone called theresa may
refused to let him publish his evidence
and she theresa may has been the biggest
problem because she is
she is religiously anti-drugs except
alcohol of course
i mean it's completely absurd she
brought in the psychoactive substances
act which is
a completely stupid piece of legislation
there was
almost no harm from psycho other psycho
substances it was all
hysteria driven by the media but also
not just the media there are some quite
powerful the puritans they got alcohol
banned in america in 1923 they're still
there
you know there are still people that
want to ban all drugs including alcohol
and their
things like the public policy exchange
they're still pushing pushing all the
time
to ban things and as i've said banning
things
almost always leads to the rise of more
toxic substances
you know it's interesting because we i
you know we talk to people from all over
the political spectrum and one of the
things that i always find uh
kind of more troubling about some of the
excesses of the left is they tend not to
think about things in a practical way
but rather in a very utopian way
but this is an issue on which the right
is completely mental when it comes to
listening because their approach is very
much that it's we can you know we can
get people not to ever use drugs again
and it just seems to be counter to the
human experience well of course it is
it's
stupid but i don't the left don't know
better
really well blair and brown blair and
brown
these million young people with criminal
records that was driven by blair
incentivizing the police making
making cannabis possession an offense
that was part of the police target was
the i mean the police is it's
the easiest crime in the world the
police would literally do this they'd
start on a shift at six o'clock
in london they'd walk into a park stop a
black guy fill in his pockets find some
cannabis
that's done i've met my criteria of
arrest for the day
off to the pub i mean it was absolutely
ridiculous and and that's one of the
reasons we had the riots
because hogan howe decided he was going
to really impose this when he came into
power
i mean you know arresting young black
people for possessing cannabis
by police who the black people know are
using a more toxic drug called alcohol
it's it's not it's it's immoral it's
racist the whole thing was just so
corrupt
and now you know there's
there's a group in the labour party that
i've been lecturing to and talking with
who want reform drug policy
but kirsten perhaps not surprisingly
given that he was a man it locked up a
lot of people for drugs
drug use says no no the labor party are
terrified
of being seen as soft on drugs
so they won't change because they're
scared in fact i think it's going to be
the tories that are going to change
sooner because
the economic value for instance of
having a regulated cannabis market is
enormous
it's going to bring brilliant billions
of pounds into the exchequer
and and actually we've saw just recently
in
i spent a lot of time advising the
norwegian experts norwegian government
on drug policy
and actually they funded some research
by us to to look at the right policies
and and we they had a vote in norway
just recently about decriminalizing drug
use who blocked it
the socialists and i think the problem
is
there's still this sort of stalinistic
view that you can control people
you know and you can stop people using
not alcohol
but you can do some other drugs and it's
so the left are just as bad as the right
i think
that's really interesting on the
politics of it the one thing i think
really pisses me off and it really does
piss me off is
look at our current prime minister boris
johnson he's admitted to using all sorts
of illegal drugs
and yet the people who are enforcing and
passing the laws
against this stuff you know we had a
whole
wave of revelations from the home
secretary jackie smith i think
uh all the way through to other members
of front benches on both sides of the
house and commons
admitting to taking drugs and yet these
are the people who are
passing laws to criminalize other people
for doing the thing they did and got
away with
yeah well of course dishonest
politicians it's not news anymore
i mean you know i mean i think the
public think what do you expect
yeah that's all they do they just lie in
line i mean it's
i just find it re i mean it is
absolutely disgusting isn't it
absolutely go michael gove can say yes
if i was caught i'd gone to prison well
he wouldn't have gone to prison because
he's white and rich
and he's got good lawyers and that's the
other thing drug policy is so racist
you know you've got i think five times
more likelihood of
being prosecuted if you're black if
you're white you know but
so he could he should have you know if
if the law was applied to him and he had
been caught everyone knew about his
cocaine parties you know
everyone knew about the alleged cocaine
[Laughter]
i don't think he denied it did he not i
don't think he ever denied it i think he
admitted he'd taken it he admitted you
know he had
misused drugs in the past and he
couldn't i think he actually said he
could have
he could have gone to prison maybe he
said he should have done but
the reality is it's
he needs to be asked the question why
are you still opposing a rational policy
maybe he'd say well
maybe if cocaine was legal i'd have
taken more it's a bit hard to imagine
how you could have done
that but you know i mean i don't i don't
know what they think i actually don't
think they
they just lie they just know that as
long as the daily mail and the son
are kept happy they'll stay in power and
that's all they're just appeasing the
newspaper editors who
who for some reason have this well i
don't know
i don't actually know if they care about
drugs i think they just find drugs in a
very easy way of stirring up interest in
the newspapers
it's amazing isn't it how it's become
this political football and we talk
about drugs and the legalization of
drugs
do you think gambling is a drug no but
gambling does
make use of the same brain circuits that
um drugs do to get you addicted so
gambling is clearly addictive
and and we we're using that fact to try
to understand
brain circuits of addiction because
we've done a lot of work on
alcoholism and on heroin and cocaine
addiction
and people say yeah you can show me
these circuits in the brain that are
altered in these people
but how do you know that's not just due
to the drug and we say well actually we
can't be sure it could just be that if
you use drugs enough and we say well
people do
people who aren't addicted to use drugs
don't have the same changes but they say
well yeah but maybe it's just these
people were
vulnerable to start with but if you
study gambling
most gamblers can't afford drugs so so
they don't use
you know they're not dependent on drugs
so then you can actually look at the
core processes
which underpin addiction and we hope
that that will give us insights into new
treatments
that's what i was going to ask you
actually because there are people
with alcohol it's it's a very well-known
thing there are people who can drink
alcohol
and never become addicted and there are
people who just cannot drink alcohol
without becoming alcoholics that's right
do we have
any idea on what the difference is
between those two people two friends
sitting next to each other and they have
completely different outcomes from the
same point
yes we do we can't predict but we can
explain
and there are several things we've
discovered that predispose you to
becoming an alcoholic
and the first one is having an alcoholic
father so there's clearly genetics
but we can go further than that now and
in fact we know that that vulnerability
is in part
due to brain chemistry and it's kind of
paradoxical but
people who who are start off being
resistant to alcohol
the people that can stay sober or stay
stay standing
after their first binge when all their
friends are on the floor
they're often they've got alcoholic
fathers and and so they they're like
pre-tolerant
now they're super sick everyone thinks
oh he's an amazing guy look how much you
can drink
but the problem is they end up drinking
more and becoming eventually become
dependent
so that's the first thing and then the
other thing is that um
we've shown that so there's the people
who drink all the time
and who like drinking all the time and
want to drink all the time because they
can but then there are the others and
this is in some ways a more common group
and we all know them the people that
that actually don't want to drink all
the time
but can't stop when they start the
binges and we've shown that the binges
they have probably some deficit of the
endorphin you know the brain's endorphin
system
the sort of natural high system uh
that's a natural opiate system
and uh and and we think what happens is
that when they start they go to the pub
absolutely totally intended i'm gonna
have two points i'm going home to a wife
and then after the second point the
endorphin system has been
turned on and then they lose control
and you know when you've all seen it and
then you know it's 15 points later and
they're getting divorced
so so there are at least two separate
chemical pathways which control
different forms of alcohol addiction
what about abuse and trauma which you
mentioned earlier uh
johanna harry who's written stuff about
i i don't know if you're familiar with
his work or what you think i know john
very well
oh you do and his book on his book on
addiction is brilliant
well that's his central thesis isn't it
that really people get addicted to drugs
because they are
they're dealing with childhood trauma
and
that has damaged the way that they
experience the world and they need
something to help them deal with that do
you do you agree with that
absolutely and in fact well it's not
just childhood trauma i mean
we know for veterans you know come back
from afghanistan or iraq you know
they've been traumatized
uh they've got ptsd
the vast majority of people with ptsd
whether it's through war or through rape
or
even to some extent it's less to car
accidents
people who cannot deal with ptsd turn to
alcohol it doesn't cure the ptsd it just
numbs the pain
and there's huge problems with alcohol
in in
people with ptsd which is actually why
we have just done a very interesting
study so
some of you may know that over the last
10 years there's been interest in using
mdma sort of pure ecstasy
to treat ptsd and it helps people
essentially overcome the emotional
memories of the trauma and a couple of
years ago me and my colleague ben cessa
in bristol
we thought well a lot of people who are
drinking alcohol excessively are doing
to
deaden their trauma so we did a study
which we just published last month
on using mdma two sessions of mdma the
same is
in the ptsd trials in people who are
drinking because of stress
and we had a phenomenal you know 80
percent of
that group were able to start drinking
for six months
which is unprecedented outcome because
our normal treatment which is just
talking therapy it's um
it's about twenty percent stay sober so
this is really exciting that we can
actually
target the cause of the drinking the
trauma or the trauma memories and help
people then not need to drink
wow that is i mean that's revolutionary
well i think so too but the problem is
of course that mdm is illegal
so actually we can't treat people so we
now you know we've got i think we have
we've got about 100 emails at least of
people saying can i
go into treatment with you and we say no
because it's illegal and if we give it
to you they'll lock me up and i'll tell
you the daily mail would love to lock me
up
so we have to change the law so that
people can at least doctors get i mean
isn't it bizarre why would a doctor not
be allowed to use a drug like mdma when
he can use a drug like fentanyl which is
way more toxic that's incredible i mean
it's just it's just the law is
completely wrong in terms of these drugs
it's it's moronic it's like i have to
get marijuana for my mum
because my mum has chronic
osteoarthritis is in pain
but the synthetic drugs that she gets
prescribed
are highly toxic you know they could you
read it the the long-term use causes
dementia stomach problems
can lead to you know ulcers cancers all
the but i can't give her marijuana to
help her with her pain
but you know we ha drug science has been
making progress here so
she can now get proper
pharmaceutical grade medical marijuana
through the drug science
2021 initiative yeah we've and you get
it at a good price
because we've negotiated with about five
different producers
to keep them the the prescription price
down to 150 pounds a month
so your mother can log into the drug
science website and get
assessed for um medical marijuana for
her arthritis i was already paying
through 2021. really do try that it's
okay it'll
it'll make life so much easier for
everyone you her
but also you can actually guarantee what
you're getting it's going to be it's
made to
pharmaceutical standard well there's a
happy ending turn into it
david listen we've run out of time uh we
there's so much more we could talk about
perhaps we'll
we'll do it another time uh but thank
you for coming on the show it's been a
pleasure
uh before first of all we're gonna ask
your last question
then we'll do some questions for our
local supporters uh but
uh before we we do go to our last
question tell everybody a little bit
about
your podcast and the other stuff that
you're doing that they can check out and
follow and where they can find you
online etc
so when i was sacked by uh alan johnson
and uh
gordon brown in 2009 um
i was pretty angry and pretty upset the
next day
a guy called toby jackson who'd made
some money
developing computerized training on the
london stock exchange
he emailed me and said what they've done
is outrageous
if i gave you the same amount of money
as the government spends on drug policy
in the acmd
would you set up a parallel organization
i said sure would and we set up in those
days it was called the iscd
independent scientific committee on
drugs now it's called drug science
all the scientists who resigned from the
acnd when i was sacked have joined it so
we
so now we have the drug science is now
the premier scientific
think tank on drugs in the world there's
no absolutely
no no competitors at all and over the 10
years we've done a lot of interesting
things like we've done these detailed
assessments of comparative harms of
drugs
we've set up a journal to publish
sensible data on
on drugs and tell the truth about drugs
and uh
we've held conferences we've set up 2021
to allow access we've now got a thousand
the thousands patient has gone into 2021
just last week so we've got
a facility in britain where people can
access medical cannabis
even though they can't get it on the nhs
and i've also set up a podcast
and uh do listen to my podcast i think
we've now got about 25 and there are
very interesting people they range from
from therapists like gabor mate who's
the sort of pioneer of
childhood stress and the using use of
psychedelics to deal with adults with
that problem
so to people like rick dublin who's
developing mdma he's campaigned for 25
years to
make mdma medicine you know and then
we've got some therapists and we've got
scientists uh people that discovered
interesting things about psychedelics
and
ketamine and cannabis etc so uh yeah do
listen
what's the podcast called for people
well it's just called the drug science
podcast the drug science podcast it's on
our website thedrugscience.org
fantastic i mean that's and
please please to everyone watching go
and give it a go and give it a follow go
give it a listen because it's very very
important work
and david the one question we always
finish all our interviews with
is always the same it's what's the one
thing we're not talking about
as a society but we really should be we
should talk be talking about
the lives lost over the last
50 years by this irrational
war on drugs 300 000
deaths in mexico alone but
when you look at the other side of the
coin
when you look at the lives lost because
people haven't had access to treatments
it's way more than three hundred
thousand so i've estimated just for
alcoholism alone
not heroin addiction other addictions
in the 50 years since lsd and psilocybin
were banned
there have been over 100 million
premature deaths from alcohol
there what they've been actually
about 300 million premature deaths and
tobacco
these are disorders which are treatable
with psychedelics
and even if only 10 of those people who
were addicted to alcohol and tobacco
were cured by psychedelics that would be
tens of millions of lives saved
and that's why i say the banning of
these drugs for research and treatments
the worst censorship of research and
treatment
in the history of the world it's more
people have died as a result of those
bans
than as a result of any other health
policy ever
it's a very important point david thank
you so much for coming on the show and
thank you for watching at home we'll be
back with another brilliant interview
like this one
or all show all of them go out at 7 p.m
uk time
take care and see you soon guys we hope
you've enjoyed this
incredible interview remember to
subscribe and hit the bell button
so that you never miss another fantastic
episode
and if you believe that the work we do
here at trigonometry is important
support us by joining our locals
community using the link below